- [Voiceover] Hey,
grammarians, hey, Paige.
- [Voiceover] Hi, David.
- [Voiceover] Today we're
gonna talk about dashes
which is a piece of punctuation,
looks kind of like this, shoop.
It's just kind of a straight line.
Later we're gonna talk about hyphens,
which look like this, shoop.
And there is a difference
between the two of them,
it's kind of confusing,
but first we're just
gonna talk about dashes,
what they are, what they do.
- [Voiceover] Okay, sounds good to me.
- [Voiceover] So, dashes
have approximately four uses.
Use number one is that
they can mark interruptions
in the structure of a sentence, as in,
"I ran to the bus stop--but the bus
"had already driven away."
So we're using this dash
to interrupt the structure
of this sentence.
- [Voiceover] Okay, but couldn't
you just put a comma there?
- [Voiceover] You know,
you're totally could,
you absolutely could use
a comma instead of a dash.
But the dash has this feeling.
And I'm gonna make up a word here,
it feels more interrupty.
- [Voiceover] Okay, right,
so a comma sort of helps
the sentence keep flowing
and the dash kind of
stops it for a second.
- [Voiceover] And even
though, grammatically,
those two sentences are identical, right,
"I ran to the bus stop, comma,
"but the bus had already driven away."
Even though that's, technically,
that means the exact same thing,
"As I ran to the bus stop, dash,
"but the bus had already driven away."
This is kind of like an abrupt cutoff.
So, like the comma,
right, the dash is uniting
these two independent clauses.
"I ran to the bus stop, the
bus had already driven away."
Right, so, like, you know, comma,
but we connect those
two independent clauses
the same way the dash but is
connecting those two clauses.
But it has a slightly
different connotation.
It's just more abrupt in
the way that it connects
these two things together.
- [Voiceover] Okay.
Also, it looks like you don't
have a space before or after
your dash, is that right?
- [Voiceover] Right.
So, originally when I drawn
it, it did look a lot closer.
But, yes, according to to
the Chicago Manual of Style
that Khan Academy uses,
it would just go word,
dash, word, then a space.
But when you're using dashes, generally,
you don't put spaces in between them,
in between words.
- [Voiceover] Right.
- [Voiceover] So that's use number one,
it can interrupt the
structure of a sentence.
Use number two for the
dash is that they can act
like parentheses in pairs.
- [Voiceover] So the
dash is in the same place
as another type of
punctuation could be again?
- [Voiceover] Correct.
- [Voiceover] Okay.
- [Voiceover] The dash,
I guess, is kind of like,
so let's look at another example sentence.
And I'll switch colors.
"The bug--which landed on
my nose--had to be the size
"of a softball."
Enormous bug.
But, Paige, as you rightly
pointed out, you know,
this is the same as
having it in parentheses.
You wouldn't have both of
these together like that.
- [Voiceover] But they do the same thing.
- [Voiceover] Yeah, they
have the exact same function.
- [Voiceover] In this case.
So when you have them
in pairs like so, it's
"The bug--which landed on
my nose--had to be the size
"of a softball."
So it's kind of this aside.
If we really wanted to,
we could take it right out
of the sentence, kind
of like an appositive,
right, with commas.
So we could say, "The bug had
to be the size of a softball."
Sentence still makes sense.
- [Voiceover] Right.
- [Voiceover] Use number three.
A dash can be used where you
would otherwise use a colon.
- [Voiceover] So, in
this case, it's gonna be
sort of introducing something, right?
- [Voiceover] Mm-hmm.
So the colon has this
linking power, right,
it can introduce ideas,
it can start a list,
you can do the same thing with a dash.
So, for example, if you
wanted to introduce an idea,
we could say.
- [Voiceover] I have only
ever wanted one thing--snacks.
- [Voiceover] Me, too, Paige.
- [Voiceover] So many snacks.
- [Voiceover] Me, too.
So, right.
So we're using this to introduce this idea
the same way that we
would had it then a colon.
- [Voiceover] Okay.
So the dash is like a little actor.
- [Voiceover] Yeah!
- [Voiceover] Yeah, the
dash is like an actor
that can use like do the jobs
of all these other punctuation marks.
- [Voiceover] Right.
- [Voiceover] So it can be parentheses,
it can be a colon,
it can be like a comma sometimes.
- [Voiceover] Wow!
- [Voiceover] That is
a talented little guy.
- [Voiceover] Seriously,
I'm very impressed.
- [Voiceover] And the fourth
use of the dash is, again,
to indicate interruptions,
but specifically to indicate
interruptions in speech.
- [Voiceover] This is like
its own little special thing.
- [Voiceover] Yeah.
- [Voiceover] It's not
acting like anything else?
- [Voiceover] Nope.
- [Voiceover] Just
indicating an interruption.
Yes, it does.
"Watch out for that--"
- [Voiceover] Wham.
So we're using this dash to say that
this sentence was
interrupted by something,
and then, you know, we
deploy the sound effect.
But it could be anything, really.
So if you're trying to write down dialogue
that is being cutoff by something,
by another person interrupting,
by an avalanche of ice
cream, I don't know,
whatever it is, then you would use a dash
at the end of the sentence.
So, no space.
So we'd go, that, dash, quotation marks.
And you wouldn't have to do any kind
of terminal punctuation,
no need for a period
or a question mark or
an exclamation point.
The dash kind of serves that role,
because it's a very fancy actor.
So I wouldn't say that the
dash as an actor can perform
the same roles as terminal punctuation,
as periods or question
marks or exclamation points,
but rather I would say that
it is cutting off the sentence
before we can even get to
where those would live.
- [Voiceover] Okay, yeah, it's saying
there would've been more
words in this sentence
and then terminal punctuation, but.
- [Voiceover] So that's
what dashes can do.
They are used to mark interruptions
in the structure of a sentence, like,
"I ran to the bus stop--but the bus
"had already driven away."
- [Voiceover] They can
act like parentheses
when they're used in pairs, so like,
"The bug--which landed on
my nose--had to be the size
"of a softball."
- [Voiceover] You can
use them like a colon
to lead into lists or to link an idea.
So, "I have only ever
wanted one thing--snacks."
- [Voiceover] And they can
indicate interruptions in speech,
like, "Watch out for that--"
- [Voiceover] Wham.
- [Voiceover] That was good.
- [Voiceover] Thanks.
And those are the functions of the dash.
- [Voiceover] You got it.
- [Voiceover] You can learn anything.
David out.
- [Voiceover] Paige out.